[Music]
[Music]
pushing ahead now just needs to keep
this kind of baked up
[Music]
[Music]
eg ahead town just has to keep going to
space for the big win
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
flopping into that next feature and
straight into the nose press nailing
that board side back slide nailing the
360 easily there and the landing was
nice and clean as well
[Music]
nailing the grass coming out of that 720
stomping that board side nose slide and
into the board side back slide switch to
180 and holding on to that amplitude as
much as possible switch into the back
flip demonstrating your basic 180 there
dominate that board site backslide with
absolute ease blowing everyone out of
the water with a triple backflip and
grab
nicely locking into that crab on the big
triple front flip
triple backflip lithograph
[Applause]
[Music]
now that is a huge amount of G's come
into that kick oh man have you ever seen
a run like this we are watching history
unfold here
coming in hot into the kicker
stomping the triple rodeo and a graph
[Applause]
unless walk on the perfect grab during
that huge triple Rodeo a ridiculous
double backflip with a grass drop me to
grab into that double truck flips
silky-smooth lost a variety from the
trick bag on show here the double
backflip with a ground miles of style
triple rodeo with a vice-like breath
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
speeding into that next turn how long
was that
that was insane gigantic look at the air
time
[Applause]
[Applause]
and not much airtime off that kicker on
the way to the wind now just need to
stay focused until the end
is that real shock turn
doing really well just needs to stay
super focused in the end
thank you much with that soft
this was too close to call how long was
that
that was insane Oh huge air time coming
to that jump
[Applause]
speedy into that next turn
you